we're on problem 79 a small business
owner must hire seasonal workers as the
need arises the following list shows the
number of employees hired monthly for a
five-month period okay so we hired four
in the first month 13 in the second
month so on if the mean of these data
remember data is plural I always say
this data but if they say they correctly
say if the mean of these data is
approximately seven so the mean is just
the average right so they're saying the
average of these numbers is seven fair
enough if you add all of these up and
divide by five you'll get approximately
seven what is the population standard
deviation for these data
so what population will you know I'll
make up I'll make a statistical playlist
one day where I talk about the different
of population standard deviation and the
sample standard deviation all that but
the population standard deviation it's
it's just so you have an intuition it's
a it's a it's a measure of on average
how far are each of these numbers from
the mean and it's not exactly how the
average of how far they are from the
mean but I'll show you that in a second
is actually the square it's it's the
square root of the average of the
squared distances of how far each of
these are from the mean and that that
might sound crazy for a second but when
you we actually work it out at all out
the math isn't too bad
so we'll do first is figure out the
variance the variance the variance and
that's the notation for the variance and
the standard deviation actually is just
the square root of this so it's easy if
you have the variance it's very easy to
figure out the standard deviation but
the variance and just to give me give
you the intuition it's equal to the
average of the squared distances squared
distances from the mean from the mean
from the mean so essentially I say okay
how far is four from seven oh it's three
away and I squared I said okay that the
squared distance is nine the squared
distance here let me figure it out so
let's actually write them down four
minus seven let me actually calculate it
so I'll do it here four minus 7 is minus
three if I were to square that I get
nine so the square of the distance from
four to seven
is nine right so that's a squared
distance so the square root of distance
from 13 to 7 see there's six apart you
square them and you and because we're
squaring it doesn't matter if we do 7
minus 13 or 13 minus 7 because the
negative times a negative is a positive
so anyway 13 minus 7 is 6 that squared
is 36 then I have 5 minus 7 that's minus
2 squared is equal to 4 then I have 6
minus 7 that's 1 negative 1 squared is
equal to 1 and then I have 9 minus 7
that's 2 squared is equal to 4 so this
the 9 is the square of how far 4 is from
7 36 is the square of how 13 is from 7
so each of these are the squared
distances right of each of the each of
the data points from the mean that's
where we got the 7 from the the average
of these numbers now we said the
variance is the average of the squared
distances which is the average of these
5 numbers so what's the average of these
5 numbers is going to be 9 plus 36 is 45
plus 4 is 49 plus 1 is 50 plus 1 is 54
so it's going to be 54 divided by 1 2 3
4 5 divided by 5 so the variance is
equal to the average of the squared
distances and that's see what 10 and 4/5
is equal to 10.8 so that's the variance
and they want to they don't want the
variance they don't want the population
variance they want the population
standard deviation well that's just the
square of the variance and you can see
since you're saying the square of the
squared distance is it kind of becomes
close to the average of the real
distances but it's actually not that and
I don't want to confuse you right now so
for the sake of this problem let's just
take the square of the square root of
this so the standard deviation is just
equal to the square root of the variance
which is equal to the square root of
10.8 and what is that we let's see 3
squared is 9 4 squared is 16 so 10 the
square root of 10 point is going to be
pretty close to 3 between 3 and 4 but a
lot closer to 3 and if we look at all
the choices the only one that even comes
close as this one I think if you
actually found the square root is
actually very close to 3 point 3 next
problem
next problem
James found the mean and standard
deviation of the set of numbers given
above if he adds five to each number
which of the following result if you add
five the mean will be multiplied by five
no no that's not right because if you
add five to each of these numbers the
mean will just become five bigger right
you're kind of just shifting over the
center to some degree D where you're
measuring the center by the average over
five actually I could even I could
actually show it to you if I said three
plus five and I'm going to avert add
that to six plus five plus two plus five
right I'm adding five to every number
plus two plus five plus one plus five
plus seven plus five plus five plus five
all of that divided by there's one two
three four five six numbers right all of
that divided by six this is the same
thing as let me write this this is it if
we you know we can get rid of the
parenthesis while we're doing is adding
so that's the same thing as three plus
six plus two plus one plus seven plus
five I just took the first terms in each
of these right plus how many fives we
have one two three four five six plus
six times five all of that over six well
this is going to be this is this so this
is equal to C 3 plus six plus two plus
one plus seven plus five over six let me
scroll down a little bit plus what's 6
times 5 divided by six
well that's just five so this is the
average of the original set of numbers
right and now when you add five to all
of them the average of all of them
combined is just going to be the
original average plus five so you're
just shifting the average to the right
so this is not right you're not
multiplying the mean by five you're just
adding five to the mean that's not right
the standard deviation will increase by
five well the last video you saw that
the standard deviation is the square
root of the variance but but either both
them are a measure of kind of the
average distance of the numbers from the
meeting or from from the average so even
if you shift everything by five right
the mean shifts by five all the number
shift by five their distances from the
mean aren't going to change actually the
standard deviation actually won't change
so this isn't right the standard
deviation won't increase won't increase
by five these numbers aren't going to
become further away from the average so
that's not right the mean will not
change well no we know that the mean
will change I just showed you that the
mean will actually increase by five all
right when all the numbers are increased
by five that's not right so we already
know the D is probably the answer but
let's make sure the standard deviation
will not change right in general the
kind of the average dispersion or how
far on average the numbers are away from
the mean won't change all the numbers
are going to increase by five and the
mean is going to increase by five so how
far the numbers are from the mean where
the variance won't change the kind of
the square of the distances won't change
if the various doesn't the various
doesn't change then the mean won't
change so the answer is definitely D and
we're all done see you in the next
playlist